and we're back live from the
Gaithersburg Book Festival EJ Dionne is
next he's in conversation about his
newest book why the write went wrong
with CNN breaking news editor David mark
thank you all so much for braving the
elements and coming out to gatorsburg
today it's great to have all of you here
and welcome to the seventh annual
Gaithersburg Book Festival I'm Lissa
Muscatine I'm the co-owner with a
politics in prose bookstore with my
husband Brad Graham who's right here in
the red coat and we and our wonderful
staff thank you guys we enter our staff
at PNP are delighted to be the
festival's official bookseller
for the fifth year in a row and we
really want to commend and thank the
city of Gaithersburg the mayor all the
festival sponsors volunteers they have
done an incredible job that you probably
aren't even aware of behind the scenes
to get ready for this weather and make
this festival a go even with all the
rain and they've done a terrific job and
we're very grateful to them for for all
that they've been through in the last 48
hours and the weeks before and of course
we thank all of you for being here just
before we get started a few
administrative notes if you have any
sort of device on you that might make an
unwelcome sound in the next hour so if
you could turn it to silent we would be
grateful if you're tweeting today from
this event please use hashtag GBF and
then lastly we hope that you'll all take
the time to fill out a survey to help
the festival's sponsors and others learn
what we can do better in the years ahead
if you complete the survey and there
copies here in the tent and also online
you have a chance to win a $100 Visa
gift card and then lastly EJ will be
signing immediately after the
presentation we do have copies of his
book in the pnp book tent which is
conveniently located about 20 steps from
here right over here so we hope you'll
visit us there for his book and and some
others and I do want to just take a
moment because I suspect all of you are
book lovers and you're also sadly for
you a captive audience for me for at
least a moment I just want to remind
everyone here that although this
festival is a free event and we want to
keep it that way
does help the festival if you buy books
here and that's because the more books
that are purchased here the more likely
publishers will be to invest in sending
authors like EJ and others to events
like this one and of course having
authors of this caliber as part of what
makes this event better and better each
year and I also just want to say on a
personal note for me and Brad and all of
our staff at P and P that we hope and
appreciate when you choose to make your
book purchases through politics and
prose during the rest of the year or
from any independent bookstore your
purchases help us strengthen our local
economy provide jobs in our community
and offer a space where citizens can
meet authors in person contribute to the
marketplace of ideas and and really be
part of our collective forum for public
discourse and this is really for us one
of the most important parts of our
mission as an independent bookstore and
we can't serve our communities in that
way without your support so thank you
all for being supporters of local
independent bookstores whether it's us
or others we're all in it together and
we appreciate having your patronage so
thank you so much at politics and prose
I think many of you have probably been
to the store and those of you who
haven't we invite you to come we have
about 500 author events a year we're
always delighted when EJ Dionne is one
of our speakers he's a longtime friend
of the store and also an old personal
and professional colleague of mine and
Brad's from our days in journalism and
my days in politics but most important
for your purposes he is a man worth
listening to
especially in this strange unpredictable
and unprecedented moment in American
politics that we currently all find
ourselves in EJ began his journalistic
career as a reporter for the New York
Times he migrated to the Washington Post
in 1990 and he became a columnist at the
post in 1993 he's also a regular
commentator on NPR and MSNBC a senior
fellow at Brookings a professor at
Georgetown and the author or editor
a dozen or so books now many of you
probably know EJ or think of EJ as a
liberal Democrat down to his DNA so you
may be a little bit surprised if you
haven't read the book yet to learn that
he actually grew up as a conservative in
a conservative family and that is where
he begins his new book which is called
why the right went wrong for EJ
conservatism is not in his words some
exotic irrational Creed
even if his own views have shifted many
years ago toward the center left today
he describes himself as quote an
unapologetic liberal of social
democratic inclinations and and I can
attest to this a temperate disposition
[Music]
but he continues to respect the
conservative tradition and believes that
it's a vital component of a balanced
vibrant democratic order I think what
Brad and I admire most about EJ and I'm
sure this is true of many of you is not
just the clarity and integrity of his
thinking but that he models exactly the
sort of intellectual engagement that is
so essential to and so often missing in
our country today and if you listen to
any of his weekly NPR commentaries where
he's paired with David Brooks the
influential conservative columnist at
the New York Times you may likely find
yourself feeling as I almost always do
and that is to say I find myself wishing
indeed praying that our wider political
discourse could be as thoughtful and
reasonable as David Brooks and EJ Dionne
are even when engaged in passionate
heated debates with one another and why
the right went wrong EJ explores what
has happened to the Republican Party and
the American conservative movement over
the past half-century this is an either
a hostile critique nor a dismissal of
the importance of the conservative
tradition it's an exposition and
exploration of why EJ feels things have
gone awry and how distressing he finds
this for our democratic values and
system
perhaps because EJ was a reporter by
trade he doesn't just pontificate he
does a lot of research before coming up
with his conclusions for this book he
reached out to a wide cast of Republican
politicians thinkers strategists and
writers and is always the case with his
work the final result is a brilliant
lucid theory of the case a timely and
needed critique of conservatism from
Goldwater in the 1960s to the peak tea
party and Trump of the present day and I
think he'll tell you a story about what
the paperback cover may say on it
because Trump's not on the current cover
you may notice and even in this
presidential year that has turned
conventional political thinking on its
head
EJ's book deepens our understanding of
the tensions and rifts within the
Republican Party offering an historical
map of how and why a more reactionary
brand of conservatism has left little
room for moderate Republicans in the
party today we're very delighted the EJ
will be in conversation today with the
wonderful David Mark a breaking news
editor at CNN politics and a former
senior editor at Politico he himself has
been an author at this event I think
last year he's written several books on
political speech
so please welcome EJ Dionne and David
mark to the Gaithersburg
well thank you very much for that
wonderful introduction and for braving
this inclement weather that we're facing
in a late made they wouldn't have
expected that but it is such a pleasure
and honor to be here with EJ I first
read why Americans hate politics when I
was in college back during President
Bill Clinton's first term going back
little ways and had the opposite effect
on me made me love politics and want to
get into this kind of crazy I was the
hidden agenda
so it's a real pleasure just personally
to be able to speak here with EJ and
just briefly one of our favorite terms
from our political language book was
quote reasonable Republicans this is
something that you often hear on Capitol
Hill from the likes of Harry Reid Nancy
Pelosi of late Hillary Clinton and the
likely Democratic nominee has picked up
on this theme to one form or another so
when I saw EJ's book was coming out
several months before I was even invited
to to be in conversation with him it was
I was thrilled to see if there was a
treatise worthy of being written in the
manner in which EJ did it Lisa
noted you have sort of an a different
ideological outlook and then the subject
matter of you book book as noted you
describe yourself early on in the book
as an unapologetic liberal of Social
Democratic inclinations and a temperate
disposition so what advantages do you
think this provides you in the analysis
and conversely why should conservatives
listen to you about the subject yeah why
should any conservative what a read a
book about them by a liberal first of
all let me say a couple of things I am
tempted to ask to shut up for the rest
of the session and just ask c-span to
run Lissa's unbelievably generous
introduction over and over again but I
don't get that kind of cable treatment
cuz I'm not talking trump so but I want
to thank this Brad and underscore what
she said about independent bookstores
you know politics pros is truly one of
the greatest bookstores in the world
because it's not simply a bookstore it's
a community organization and it can be
the asset and that's true of all the
great bookstores like it around the
country I want to thank David yeah let's
I want to thank David and he is an
expert on political language and sound
bytes so by the end of this day but I
want you to give me the five sound bytes
certain to get everybody in the room out
there buying my boy including bless
c-span for broadcasting this I always
tell people you don't think of it as
buying a book I have five more years of
college tuition to pay so you are
contributing to the education of my
daughters the I want to thank the city
of Gaithersburg for this my wife
actually worked for some years for the
city of Gaithersburg on affordable
housing I want to thank the current
mayor council mayor Katz I guess they
call him now was mayor then I when my
wife was there and there was some great
people that my wife got close to Louise
Kaufman Karen Sims and some of you how
many people here actually are from
Gaithersburg because I bless you because
one of the people very dear to us who
passed away too young was Jeff Sims and
some of you may remember was the JV
coach at quince orchard High School and
our son played basketball for Whitman
and we had some wonderful and my wife is
actually a good athlete I always say my
children have all the athletic talent
that their father doesn't and their
mother does and we still mourn Jeff
Schloss but bless Gaithersburg for doing
this and thank you all for braving this
rain they let baseball fans go under you
know have protection but we go on to go
to the question I did write this book as
somebody who grew up a conservative you
know my oh I want to thank by the way my
cousin Susan Truman and her husband
Patrick whom I haven't seen in a long
time it's so great for them and they
know perfectly well that our family had
a long Republican tradition her mom was
actually elected a tax collector in the
City of Waterbury Connecticut in 1965 on
the Republican ticket it would say John
Lindsey were forming were
ticketed in the City of Waterbury and
you my I had a relationship with my dad
where we loved to argue and my dad was a
very open-minded guy and he actually
encouraged me to argue with him he gave
me his ice plate wasn't a mistake he
knew what he was doing but he gave me a
subscription to The New Republic that I
had asked for when I was 13 years old
and I would say I changed my politics I
am a completely odd person because the
Great Society actually encouraged me to
change my politics around the time I and
when I was 12 I was a Goldwater right I
tell the story in the book about
watching the famous Goldwater speech a
time for choosing and my dad and I
knowing at that moment the Reagan's
speech for Goldwater where every
conservative in the country including us
identified by Ronald Reagan as a guy who
is gonna say the conservative movement
and typical for me just as the moment
was on its way up I got out and moved to
the other side I grew up a Red Sox fan
so I am an underdog yes by Nature
but I looked at the Great Society and
said hey wait a minute these liberals
and Democrats are trying to solve
problems that actually need to be solved
and so I passed through a period of
being a liberal Republican and then
decided eventually that didn't work very
well and the other thing that influenced
me a lot and some of you may have had an
experience like this I was in a religion
class in my public high school then we
had to read a religious book and I chose
to read Martin Luther King's book
strength to love which if you never read
it is a really wonderful book cause it's
a collection of dr. King's sermons it
really made me look at the world at
racial justice and social justice in a
different way but so but after all these
years of journalism and commentary you
know I wrote this book because like a
lot of people and mainly people on my
side of politics but I think a lot of
other people I was very frustrated with
what conservatism had become I was
frustrated by the obstruction in the
Obama years certain people who some one
of whom is very prominent now who even
denied the legitimacy of President
Obama's election by claiming that he
hadn't been
born in the United States and this
wasn't the conservatism that even as I
became a liberal I had continued to
respect and so why should a conservative
read this book well fortunately for me
that one of my favorite reviews of this
book was actually by Henry Olson in
National Review the kind of flagship
publication of the right and he asked
the same question he said why should any
conservative read this and he agreed
with my premise that he disagreed with
other things in the book I don't want
Henry's reputation destroyed he's a good
conservative but he agreed with my
premise that the Republican Party since
Goldwater has been locked into a view
that it hasn't been able to get out of
that the core argument of the book is
the first sentence of the book is the
history of contemporary American
conservatism is a story of
disappointment and betrayal and what I
argue is ever since Goldwater
conservative politicians have had to
make a series of promises they couldn't
possibly keep one was to reduce the size
of government well ever since Goldwater
neither Nixon nor Reagan nor either
President Bush could reduce the size of
government why is that
- great analysts of public opinion back
in the 1960s lured free and had Lee
Cantrell described Americans as
ideological conservatives and
operational liberals that basically
means that we have a mistrust of
government but we actually want
government to do quite a lot of stuff
and I think the best example of this are
members of the Tea Party who often said
they wanted to reduce the size of
government there they go by a buy in
that train they want to reduce the size
of government but please don't cut
Medicare or Social Security now it's
sure accident that many of them might be
at near or over the age of 65 but it's
true of all of us we want things from
government and the other two key
promises were to rollback the cultural
changes of the 60s now there continues
to be resistance to various aspects of
that to civil rights but I don't think
it's very clear a majority of Americans
not only don't want to go back
but when you look at the gains made by
the gay rights movement in such a long
period of time a lot of Americans want
to continue a journey toward greater
toleration and in pusun this and then of
late they've sort of promised to remake
the ethnic makeup of the country back to
where it was around 1950 you can't do
that without deporting say 11 million
people most Americans know that so I'll
stop here we could because I've gone on
too long in my first so-called answer to
your excellent question but the you know
this this produced a cycle of
radicalization and disappointment which
produced Donald Trump I quote Erik
Erikson of red state the conservative
commentator who said the Republican
Party created Donald Trump because they
made a lot of promises that they didn't
keep well speaking of Donald Trump the
presumptive Republican nominee he
actually makes a cameo appearance of
sort in your book early on oh I want to
say more than a camera well in in the
debate over the Panama Canal treaty in
the late 1970s and you you say that he
kind of prefaced he looked forward to
the make America great slogan again I'm
wondering where you think Trump fits on
the continuum of Republican conservative
politics over the year both of the years
both substance subsidy and stylistically
yeah no that's a great question there is
a just so you know I was writing I wrote
the first draft of this book and then
Trump started to emerge in the summer of
2015 and fortunately for me a there was
already a fair amount of Trump in the
book B Trump broadly fit in with the
argument of the book and so there I had
had a chapter in the early draft of the
book on the reform conservatives people
who are trying to change the movement
and I altered that chapter a bit and
it's now called reforming conservatism
or trumping it in which I talk about
Trump and the make America great again
slogan was actually a Reagan slogan and
I think when you hear that slogan what's
very important to think about is the key
word in that slogan is again because a
the implication is we're not great
more and B the only way forward is
backward which is essentially you know
in some deep sense at the heart of the
the Trump campaign Trump is I think
peculiar to the Republican Party because
a he was a longtime Democrat every day
it seems he takes a position that is
somehow contradicted by something he
probably said 10 15 20 years ago
but he is a he represents a very
particular wing
he's part tea party although the tea
party movement I think in this election
split between Trump and Ted Cruz she's
the part of the Tea Party that was more
nativist more restriction astana bortion
in some cases more reactive on race I'll
use I'll put it that way politely and
that that a lot of that part of the Tea
Party voted for him he is also the
candidate of the white working class in
the Republican Party and one of the
another central argument of the book is
that the Republican Party is dependent
on votes from white working-class
Americans and has delivered nothing for
it for them over the years and that's
not just some liberal social democrat
like me saying this in the book I quote
governor Tim Pawlenty former governor
Tim Pawlenty of Minnesota who talked
about the Republicans as the party of
Sam's Club I quote two very smart
conservative writers Ross Douthat whom
Semmy read in the New York Times and
reihan Salam who wrote a book saying
basically that if the Republican Party
does not actually start delivering
something to these warden class
supporters they're going to be in a heap
of trouble that heap of trouble is
Donald Trump and he picked up in a way
where Rick Santorum left off in the last
campaign remember Rick Santorum also
became the voice of working-class
Republicans and you know a lot of people
come to my events or liberals so just
for fun I want to say a nice word about
Rick Santorum I don't know if any of you
ever saw his victory speech after the
Iowa caucuses but it was this
quite beautiful speech or he was talking
about his grandfather or miner and he
noted that his grandfather's hands were
all gnarled and from that work and said
tourim looks up and says those hands dug
freedom for me it was one of the great
lines I've ever heard from a politician
I don't agree with Rick Santorum on much
of anything but I love that line but it
also spoke to this working-class part of
the Republican Party and then the last
thing about Trump that I think is most
surprising is you know how did he nail
down this nomination he got to where he
was with victories in very conservative
states like Arkansas Tennessee Alabama
but he nailed it down in states like New
York and Pennsylvania and I think oddly
Trump and Stan Greenberg the Democratic
pollster wrote a very good piece on this
there were a lot of moderate Republicans
who felt they had no place to go because
on social issues even more moderate
sounding candidates like John Kasich
were actually quite conservative so
Trump by default also picked up some
moderate Republican votes so we had this
very peculiar coalition and it's one
reason why there are still a lot of
conservatives who don't trust him
neoconservatives think he is not
interventionist enough on foreign policy
fiscal conservatives wonder or will he
know is he a deal maker we'll be happy
to make any sort of deal with the
Democrats on the budget and the real
truth of Donald Trump is no one actually
knows where he stands which will either
be a great asset or a great liability
before this campaign is over
do you write at length about the most
recent Republican president george w
bush and you actually express some
sympathy for his intentions if not
necessarily his actions particularly on
the faith-based initiative which was
largely forgotten it occurred largely
before 9:00 and what 9/11 it got some
soon bye-bye world events but explain
what you think could have could have
happened that what was the potential in
that kind of idea Mike Gerson some of
you know a columnist for The Post who
was George Bush's speech writer and
at times during the Bush administration
I was sympathetic to compassionate
conservatism in terms of where I thought
it might go and ended up being critical
of it in practice because I didn't think
they took it very far and then we're
reluctant to spend public money to begin
with on programs for the poor except for
his very good initiative in Africa the
PEPFAR initiative which he deserves real
credit for but I once told Mike who is
really the early compassionate
conservative that I didn't realize how
much I'd miss compassionate
conservatives until they all disappeared
but what I argue is Bush had to lost
opportunities that when he ran for the
first time but you know in 1999-2000 he
understood that the Republicans had
really lost a lot of ground to Bill
Clinton and he was trying to remake the
image of the party so he made a point of
talking a lot about education and in
fact the No Child Left Behind law which
a lot of people became critical of later
passed through the support of a lot of
liberal Democrats including Ted Kennedy
and George Miller of California and he
used faith in a very interesting way
because you know he talked about
rallying the armies of compassion in the
country and he was specifically talking
about all the people who did work with
churches and synagogues and mosques now
the problem with compassionate
conservatism I argue is twofold one is
that at times it simply seemed more like
a slogan than a program I actually talk
in the book about an interview I have
with George Bush back in 1998 when he
was running for governor I said you know
this is all very convenient for you this
faith thing because you know your
conversion allows you to draw a line in
your life at age 40 so no one can go
back and look at what happened before it
appeals to a big chunk of the Republican
Party the evangelical conservatives but
also you can appeal to moderates and
liberals because you sound like you care
about the
and that was the only time they're gonna
be really at stealing with me and he
looked at me and said you know if it
were that cynical people would figure it
out which I realized wasn't direct
answer to the question but anyway it was
a euro and so there was that side of it
but I think that there was part of Bush
for whom this was a real thing but the
other problem was philosophical the
compassionate conservatives I thought
and I still think fall into two
categories one were conservatives who
really did have a bad conscience about
the failure of conservatives to lift up
the poor and they were looking for
alternative ways of lifting up the poor
that would include government support
not only for religious institutions but
for the third sector and there are
people like Mike Gerson or the late
David quo John do you Leo my friend who
ran the faith based always actually
Democrat who ran the faith-based office
for about six months before he left the
Bush administration he later even though
he stayed close to bush he later
described the Bush administration as
Mayberry Machiavelli's which is an
interesting formulation he didn't want
to be quoted on that but somebody did
anyway because he's not it he doesn't he
doesn't like to attack like that you
know and but those folks were serious
but there are a lot of other people who
simply want to reduce the size of
government and figure well we'll just
let the churches take care of it it
became excuse for dismantling government
and so in the end you know a couple of
things happened one 9/11 happened so
that whole emphasis became secondary or
tertiary to Bush and a lot of
Republicans in Congress never liked the
compassion agenda I had a great
interview with my friend Mike Gerson who
said they just didn't want to play ball
on this at all and so I thought that was
the first opportunity he lost to create
a new Republican Party the second was
after 9/11 where I argue that he could
have created a kind of Eisenhower
Republican Party again at that moment of
genuine national unity and he went in a
different direction and
you know became went back to rallying
the base and became a much more divisive
figure especially after the Iraq
invasion which unlike Afghanistan did
not have this it never had the same kind
of support that Afghanistan then we
certainly want to open up to audience
questions so if get your questions ready
that's one more and then a bit open up
the floor briefly in Marsh House Speaker
Paul Ryan relatively new speaker gave a
speech in which he expressed regret even
apologies for using the makers and
takers line of the 2012 campaign when of
course he was Mitt Romney's running mate
I wonder what you make of this if in
your view this is a sign of progress
well it's a sign of a kind of progress
that he's walking away from the words
the question is will he from my point of
view make progress by walking away from
the policies that underlay it I'm very
critical in the book of the makers and
takers language you know it's I point
out that Paul Ryan was very devoted to
an R and as a young man and I can never
resist pointing out that one of Iran's
books was called the virtue of
selfishness and I really do think that
the Ryan budget SAR the problem more
than the words but I do think there were
conservatives after the Romney campaign
I have I have fun you know a long
description of what went wrong for Mitt
Romney and an analysis of the whole the
whole of the 47% speech and you know if
the the idea here is that people who are
dependent on the state for some of their
lives are somehow takers it's as if all
government investment in people simply
promotes dependency and that's flatly
wrong I mean the government helped me go
to college you know the government I
benefited from student loans and Social
Security benefits and veterans benefits
after my dad died government invested in
me and I pay back more in taxes
and I ever took out that's true of a lot
of Americans it's true of all the
Americans who went to college on the GI
Bill now granted everybody's person to
you I feel because we say rightly those
vents earned it nonetheless that was an
investment a by a government in people
and there are plenty of Americans who at
various moments in their life for know
through no fault of their own become
dependent for a while on this help but
the idea I've always liked is John
Stuart Mill's idea that they got the
purpose of this government help is what
you want is help toward doing without
help and I think we spend way too much
time focusing on you know the problem of
dependency and yeah there are some
people who stay dependent for a long
time their enormous numbers of Americans
who needed some help along the way and
then in order to become self-sufficient
and and so the whole makers and takers
idea is Florida in that way and it's
fought another way and Paul Ryan is a
very serious Catholic and he does speak
about the poor sometimes with real
compassion well what is this about some
of our brothers and sisters are you know
I don't have the same good fortune that
the rest of us might have at a given
moment in our lives and I don't think
you know I was glad that conservatives
took the word compassion because so much
of conservatism is asserting that
somehow being a bleeding-heart is a bad
thing and let me just tell one story on
that if I may it's um one of my favorite
it is not in the book I don't think but
it's all my favorite stories covering
politics it was when Mario Cuomo ran for
mayor of New York and lost and there's a
wonderful conservative talk show host
called Barry Farber real
arch-conservative running in the primary
and he happened to be speaking to a
group of African American ministers and
he started attacking bleeding heart
liberals and one of the ministers at the
end of his speech stood up tall Tim
Mitchell was his name and Reverend
Mitchell looks at Barry Farber and says
mr. Farber I worship a savior in the
bleeding heart
one of my favorite moments ever in a
campaign well on that note we'd love to
open up the floor yes oh sorry I took
we're over here and then we'll switch ah
I pretend for a second do you think that
Ronald ray that do you think Ronald
Reagan deserves the adulation that the
Republican Party assigns damn today I
mean the short answer is no in the sense
of my politics are different from Ronald
Reagan's so I don't feel the same way
conservatives do I oppose some of the
things Reagan did as president on the
other hand I understand where it comes
from and you know in the book I talk
about how Ronald Reagan might have
difficulty winning a Republican primary
at the moment here's what I certainly
give Ronald Reagan credit for myself as
a progressive which is the way the Cold
War ended and I think ironically you
know this great debate over how did
Reagan bring the cold water when in my
conservative friends would tend to focus
on the military buildup and Reagan being
very tough but I argue that if that's
all you focus on you leave out the fact
that Reagan understood before most
people that Gorbachev was actually
someone we could do business with that
was Margaret Thatcher's phrase she saw
it too and that Reagan never liked
nuclear weapons and it's worth
remembering about Ronald Reagan he
didn't intervene in very many foreign
conflicts the only war he fought was in
Grenada
which had an army of about a hundred
people and you know if you remember when
the Marines were blown up in that tragic
episode in Lebanon I was actually
covered that war and interviewed the
Marines about a month before and they
were saying they were questioning what
are we doing here
so I disagreed with Reagan's decision to
put them there but he pulled them out
right away he did not go to war so that
side of Reagan I very much respect the
other part of reg and I respect is you
know if you look at him Reagan is a
complicated figure by my
chapter on Reagan in the book is called
the ambiguous hero and I argue that on
the one hand conservatives are right who
wants to see him as an ideologue and he
certainly held to conservative
principles you can't listen that speech
he made for Goldwater or not think he
was an ideologue but he tended to have
to govern both as governor California
and as president with Democrats in the
legislature in California and in
Congress and when he came to Washington
and he was willing to do business with
with Democrats to govern the country
Chris Matthews wrote a book about tip
and the Gipper and so all those sides of
Reagan I do respect and the other thing
is I really like Reagan for having a
sense of humor I like all politicians
who have a sense of humor including the
ones I vote against but thank you for
the question
if I could just add briefly my own sense
is there's still a debate among the
modern conservative movement how much to
rely back on Reagan and that he's been
out of office for 27 years now but
nobody else has really come along of
that stature so it's almost an oldie but
goodie at this point
well I quote an article that a couple of
conservative was wrote where the title
was if he were alive today Ronald Reagan
would be 103 years old that now point
was I think that was the date that was
his age when they wrote that article and
you know their point was you know you
can't just keep recreating Reaganism
night at 2016 is not 1980 the problems
of 2016 are not the same as the problems
of 1980 so there are a lot of
conservatives who say that younger
conservatives I think are especially
likely to say you know how can we keep
talking about this event of 30 years ago
now in fairness to conservatives you
know progressives we progressives still
talk about FDR and you know rightly so I
my wife gave me a poster for Christmas
once of my favorite you and the
Roosevelt Truman poster from 1944 you
know so I accept the how you honor your
past but I think a lot of conservatives
say we can honor the pass
but we got a face now just as Democrats
had to do with FDR yes sir you touched
on the occult the end of the Cold War
and Reagan's rollin in the core it seems
to me what I want to see what you think
about this a lot of the problems
Republicans have had is the fact that
Cold War has ended it seems like before
during the Cold War being anti-communist
was something the United different types
of Republicans together since the Cold
War has ended like starting in 1992 is
the first election after the Cold War
they've only won the Elector the popular
vote for president once you know so it's
it do you really mean that's a major
thing the fact that this was a major
sort of organizing principle for
religious conservatives and foreign
policy concerns and economic and service
and now that it's over the Cold War
ended they're sort of a bit unmoored now
that's an excellent observation I think
a lot of conservatives would agree with
at least some of what you said that you
know in the classic formulation when
National Review magazine started by the
way for people one of this book is
broadly even though I make arguments
this book is broadly a historical book
that takes us from 1964 forward through
the various presidencies the you know
conservatism was an alliance of
traditionalists who later kind of took
the form of the religious right although
religious right isn't exactly the same
as traditionalist conservatism
free-market people including libertarian
leaning people and then cold warriors
and those groups actually had real
differences with each other the more
libertarian conservatives were never
wild about the Cold War for example the
traditionalist conservatives were never
always fans of the free market they
valued things you know they've saw faith
and many other matters is more important
than the market and the economy
nonetheless you know National Review
created a doctrine called fusion ISM
which sort of held these together and
certainly anti-communism could unite
them and in a way anti-communism and
anti liberalism
a you know could hold them together the
the large enemy abroad and then you know
the I I'd like to think most
conservatives felt the less dangerous
said to me at home although in the
McCarthy period it wasn't clear they saw
any some of them saw any difference and
the end of the Cold War
not only took away some of the glue that
held the coalition together but it's
split conservatives cuz a lot of
conservatives Pat Buchanan way back when
talked about this Rand Paul talks about
this Ted Cruz and Donald Trump talked
about this a little bit a lot of
conservatives who are against big
government don't like a big military
don't like military intervention and as
long as the enemy was communism they
were ready to be interventionist but
after that was after the Soviet Union
fell a lot of conservatives who returned
to they are anti interventionist roots
so you do have a real split on the right
even on that fundamental issue so your
your point is I think is well taken I
talk about some of the problems with
holding this coalition together
conservatives aren't unique in having
coalition management problems as
Democrats are noticing at the moment but
they have a very particular
philosophical set of problems that
they've been struggling with for about
seventy years I do think that's
interesting that what Trump brings up a
real anti interventionist strain that in
some ways even overlaps with Saint
Bernie Sanders supporters and those much
further to the left end of the spectrum
yet Trump is hard to read because he
doesn't want to intervene and he wants
to bomb the heck out of whomever and so
I suppose you send a lot of airplanes
out or something but it is nobody but he
does have that you know he claims he was
against Iraq which is not it's not
they've all cleared that he actually was
against the Iraq war initially later
said he thought it was a mistake a lot
of people said it was a mistake later
but he does have that any
interventionist strain in at least at
times in his writer getting so did Ted
Cruz at times oh can i retake both
Nationals hats because I think we're
running low on time so if we could test
if you vote yeah
holidays I can skip the hard question
this way Republicans have said from day
one especially Marco Rubio that Barack
Obama is the most polarizing president
in American history you talk in the book
about the dinner that was held at the
caucus room the night of his first
inauguration
what were they basically Ryan and
McCarthy and several others got together
and said we're going to oppose
everything he stands for and then
McConnell comes out two weeks later with
our main goal is to make him a one-term
president if Obama was polarizing aren't
the Republicans ten times as polarizing
I'm so tend to do this say yes I just by
the way thank you for citing the book
because I do tell that story and I think
the problem with hanging us all on Obama
is that as I write in the book I'm
Robert Draper a journalist wrote a great
account of this which I quoted my book
so I want to credit him this caucus room
meeting was on the very day of Obama's
inauguration where they decided we're
gonna fight him and fight him in on the
first very first vote on the stimulus he
didn't get a single Republican vote in
the house even though the whole house of
cards that our economy look like at that
moment was threatening to come down and
then McConnell laid out a similar
strategy about a month later so you know
in the notion of blaming Trump on Obama
the guy who denied the legitimacy of his
presidency well sure yeah I suppose
every president is responsible for
everything that happens on his watch and
yeah I wish we could have done more as a
country about the suffering of
working-class people some of whom are
voting for Trump
but hanging this on Obama to me is like
blaming the guy who wants to stop the
fight for starting the fight but so
thank you for that a sympathetic
question there was somebody with a yeah
please Richmond marathon hands that's
okay I admire you for running marathons
on the on the media show Brooke
Gladstone commented that 77% of the
comments made by Donald Trump that were
fact checked are pants on fire or four
Pinocchios verses 23 to 24 percent of
Hillary Clinton's what would you say to
Trump supporters that would say would
you listen to facts
and discount the lies and my other
question would be can you address the
role of the unspoken role of racism in
both parties Wow the the no I your
accurate about Trump's inaccuracy I mean
this it is remarkable to me and and this
isn't just again a liberal view and a
lot of conservatives very frustrated
with this all through the primaries that
he seems to be held to a different
standard or he just kind of pushes the
standards aside and I'm very curious
what kind of Sanders the media is gonna
hold him to I mean you know I'm in the
media and you know if you look at
television and cable media the amount of
free time that Trump has gotten compared
to every other person who ran for
president or is still running is
astonishing at one point I would look to
my wife I was in the kitchen I said you
know what do we have now Trump state
television you know and so it's very
disturbing so I think you're seeing some
of the accountability starting to happen
and again my conservative friends said
why didn't the media do that during the
primaries you might have had a different
result but I think it's gonna be a real
challenge to the media because he can't
seems to slide right by it in terms of
race I don't that's a long answer I take
race very seriously in the book I argue
that conservatives have to come to terms
of the fact that racial reaction was at
the heart of the creation of this
conservative coalition beginning with
Goldwater Goldwater himself was not a
racist he supported the local civil
rights measures in Arizona but he voted
against the 64 Civil Rights bill his a
language on civil rights in terms of
federal power and property rights
mirrored the language of the
segregationist and you know you had a
complete flip in that started as I
argued the book under the new late in
the New Deal where Democrats had been
the party of segregation and the south
and the whole grass the whole center of
gravity of republicanism shifted from
north to south
still something that Republicans are
struggling with and you can see this and
some of the things Trump says and some
of the attitudes of his supporters and
language that Reagan used like about
welfare queens I mean there's a lot of
you know what the difference is whereas
before race was done through a dog
whistle sometimes Trump is doing it
through a bullhorn it's a very odd shift
but it's you know it is there and and
you know Democrats have their long paths
to answer for and Republicans have the
present said in the more recent past to
answer for here and ask what may be the
final question there's a whole set that
you described toward the end of the book
about so-called reform ax cons these are
conservative thinkers intellectuals who
are really trying to chart that new
vision you alluded to some by name
earlier wonder if you really think this
is something new and innovative or kind
of a repackaging of the old-time
religion the I'll give a Clintonian
answer yes you know both in a way in
other words on the one hand I think some
of the reformer cons are serious in
addressing the fact that other than
supporting tax cuts for the wealthy and
deregulating business we're
conservatives you used to be very proud
of being policy enervate errs have kind
of given up on that and so they are
trying to be more innovative in policy
and so I think there's a certain
seriousness there there but I also take
them they I argue in the book and I
think Trump's victory actually shows
this that they are they still can't
fully break with you know a view that
says we really don't trust government to
act and that you really can't farm out
government to you know the third sector
consistently I don't think and I don't
think that when they talk about
decentralization I don't think they want
to face up to centralization of power in
the private economic sphere or the role
of monopolies in the private economic
sphere they just don't have an economics
but if we are near the close here what I
would
to do is say I so I have some hope for
them but I don't think they're there yet
but some of them but I think they're
intellectually serious people but where
I would like the Republicans to kind of
and conservatives to think again is
about where what the alternative was
when Goldwater came along and with
apologies to supporters of Adlai
Stevenson in the audience both on c-span
and here I have a lot of nice things to
say about Dwight Eisenhower because I
think I represented the alternative form
of conservatism and I do think Ike was a
conservative Joe Scarborough actually is
one person who agrees with me obvious he
once said that conservatives have to
stop looking at Ike as liberal in golf
shoes and that Ike was somebody who
believed in fiscal prudence certainly
believed in a strong America was prudent
in the use of American power but
believed in a strong America he believed
in a public role for religion there were
a lot of you know public religion became
much more prominent in the 50s in our
public life but he also said there is a
role for government too big Ike programs
two of the biggest programs in history
the interstate highway system and I
talked to a Republican who quit Congress
he said because we can't even pass a
transportation bill anymore so the
interstate highway system and the
federal student loan program that help
people like me and millions of others go
to college but he was trying to preserve
the American Way of life and that was
the goal of a conservative he felt that
you didn't roll back all the changes
made in the New Deal because they
responded to certain needs of the
country and Ike was obviously
pro-business so I like Ike's a line that
I used in at the end of the 1952
campaign I like conservatives to do two
things I think they need more of what
Sarah Palin called the Hopi changee
thing I think conservatives are too
gloomy about what America is now too
gloomy about the changes the country is
going through I think that we are
potentially in one of the strongest
positions we
ever been and if we were such an awful
country we wouldn't have an immigration
problem because all kinds of people
wouldn't want to come here the way they
want to come here now but secondly I
think they need to listen to Ike who
said that neither a wise man nor a brave
man lies down on the tracks of history
to wait for the Train of the future to
run over him the country is changing I
do not think it's changing for the worse
in many ways it's changing for the
better and the odd thing is in order to
conserve you sometimes need to change
it's something Edmund Burke the
conservative hero understood and I'd
like conservatives to go back to their
Burke well I hate to say this but we are
out of time thank you so much
[Applause]
EJ will be signing and you can get
copies on a book in the politics of
burns book 10 so thank you all so much
for coming thank you Jane David
I do
and that was EJ Dionne discussing the
changes within the conservative movement
next up in about 10 minutes
New York Times reporter James risin
talks about his latest book pay any
price greed power and endless war